hello everybody my name is markiplier
and uh oh yeah okay and welcome to let's
play primal fears now this is a pretty
intense game as you imagine it is
actually a run-and-gun
a sort of game from a top perspective
you'll see in a bit but this came out
just yesterday I believe and I'm
actually pretty interested in checking
it out it looked really good from the
trailer and it wasn't very much it's an
indie game I don't think it's a full
triple-a title but yeah this is what I
saw from the trailer it looked like this
really cool style game and I kind of
liked these type of games and see um I'm
not gonna buy anything just yet I don't
know what to spend money on so I better
get into it before I know what I'm doing
collect a mission okay
Hospital on normal let's start it out
just to get a feel what we're doing like
um that was this game that was released
by Valve o algo called Alien Swarm and
that was one of my favorite ones and
it's this style game and that one at
aliens this one has like mutant zombies
or something and obviously you know yeah
you're there there that that that that's
the thing whatever that was now this
isn't exactly you know a terrifying
horror game it's not gonna have the
immersion of other stuff but once what's
really cool about this game and what I
need your help with
if deciding if whether I should do it or
not and giving this game a try is this
game it also has a four player co-op
potential so I want to know if you guys
enjoy the game enough or at least enjoy
watching it enough to go through the
trouble getting yamimash and a couple
other people to try and play some four
player co-op with me so we'll find out
just as soon as we get through this
first level man this gun is not very
powerful you know for what looked like
an m16 or something like that I don't
know my guns I would think that they
shoot a little faster than this do those
explode no they do not
looks like they would explode
I don't know what I'm supposed to do I
can't seem to carve through whoa it did
explode I can't seem to carve through
them enough to get to progress at all I
keep having to back up anyway why there
we go kind of clearing them out a bit
nothing too intense just yet but I guess
it's got to start out pretty slow just
cuz our guns or my gun sucks some money
do I have an objective is there a map
nope doesn't look like it I'm guessing
that the game just starts out quite slow
hey back up hey Nagamani
oh I from a the game starts out slow to
allow some ramped up time and getting
used to the game mechanics and I'm
pretty sure that later in the game it
gets really really really intense or at
least it should if it's any sort of good
yeah this is I I found this game before
even any real reviews came out about it
so you know I'm kind of going in blind
but I want to give it a try where'd you
come from
get out of here let me try it back up
get back get out of here you ain't got
nothing yeah I guess he heard me just a
little bit all right hey can i how do I
destroy the planks shoot him shoot him
what's over there hey what are these
sinks anywhere are these zombie mutants
have to use the shop ooh can I upgrade
frequency that's what I want I want more
fire rate that's what I need more than
anything and a little more damage and
that'll do for now okay what do we got
ah that's much better thank you
thank you much okay this F to use oh
hello
Hey okay this is what I meant by it's
gonna get more intense aww I can't even
get out of here you kidding me Jesus
there's tons of them he kind of ramped
up the difficulty pretty quick there eh
hey get away get away get away get away
get away that wasn't so bad
these little buggers don't know anything
I do like the environment and the
graphics and everything is physically
interactable it seems I mean obviously
this this is about as close to a
triple-a tunnel than in any game it's
gonna get hey come on excuse me pardon
me need to get out of here I mean it's
got really good lighting really good um
really good animation on the whole thing
I mean it's hard to see the details when
you're this far up but either way it's
still looking good get out of here get
out of here
what is this how how have I died did how
did I die
I guess those big things were on me for
a little quite a bit I didn't know where
they go though okay either way I'm gonna
I'm gonna just hold this until I can get
it got it
whatever that did I'm not exactly sure
oh you squeaky little bastards I have
grenades can I use them get out of my
way what the octa bollocks God God God
dear oh gosh darn it get out my way get
out of my way
why are you in ER how do you Jesus these
things are good if they can just go
straight on an intercept course
write to me oh I'm going down bone dumb
phone dumb bone houses even fair
that's how about album no God you know
you get away get away get away get away
get away get oh oh Jesus this is
supposed to be a normal right holy crap
is tough maybe it's like scaled up to be
four player co-op right off the bat I
didn't even reload oh wow
they're coming out of everywhere Jesus
this seems like excessive amount you can
buy I'm such a why do I only have twenty
bullet clip what is that crap that's
crap that's bull that's bull that's such
bull whoo how did I just heal myself
somehow my health went up why how I
don't care I'm just grateful don't
question it just happened guy here you
big jerk yeah big jerk get out of here
think you can mess with me
well look at the fire hydrant go her
fire extinguisher get out get out get
away get away get away no no stop moving
you little bugger
ah Jesus Christ
these things are sons of [ __ ] oh they
drop health kits okay jeez these things
are little [ __ ] it's hard to tell
when I get damaged too there's a little
red splotch but that's about it
oh man this would be much easier if I
could coordinate my efforts get like one
guy running and distracting I think this
might be made specifically to be played
in four player co-op I could imagine if
it scales up in the number of monsters
this would be pretty insane because this
if this is just the beginning
then holy hell it's gonna get crazy
later I don't even know what this is
doing oh it's turning out the steam so I
can go in that room okay man I imagine
that this like adding even one person
would just be insane so I'm starting to
think that this would be a good idea to
do some four player co-op with some
other guys
yeah maybe a lady let's see here
hop sneaking up in you look like a bush
a bit of shrubbery nope okay Oh what
how'd you come right out of the walls
how that is hardly fair yeah my wake it
on my way oh you big guys don't get it
doc you're not gonna kill me again jeez
get get get get get get get get miss
miss how they able to hit me from that
far away die die die die die die die die
god damn it these things are pains in
the ass a pain in my ass you're not
gonna kill me you son of a [ __ ] okay
there is no save system it's all based
on checkpoints so here we go plant this
l-bomb so what's my Ramos bundu oh I can
melee where'd you come from
where did these [ __ ] come from are
you kidding me where the hell did they
come from they just came out of nowhere
how's that even fair
oh man I know I'm bitching a lot I'm
just I'm just messing around I'm not
really that mad I mean I mean come on it
does seem a little unfair that they just
came out of nowhere like that they are
pretty good at evading my fire to some
good programming on the AI programmers
heart but enough of that let me just
plant the stupid bomb before you kill me
please let me figure out what's going on
oh no it's gonna blow hi barn to Timmy
George gonna blow boom a bang II okay so
let me guess more math [ __ ]
God Brawley cool I like the lighting you
know it's really cool because all the
details in this tiny object from this
point of view or casted nope nope nope
nope nope nope nope I wonder how much
damage the melee does you're gonna find
out aha
not bad it's not bad at all I mean I did
soften him up with my gun but it's still
not bad I only took about three hits I
think it's gonna may never push a boost
you out of the way I'm gonna boost you
anybody does somebody want to come over
here and step with me I'll get some
melee up in here oh yeah one shot Oh
with that I'm reloading but no done Matt
oh you're a big uns you're a fatty
let's see you see I really don't know
what this disease is if it is a disease
or if these are aliens I'm assuming that
it's some sort of disease infection
that'll be the most logical at this
point wait a minute
I got a sprint bar but it was kind of
depleted
oh I see is there a sprint mechanic here
is there some way to sprint and I'm not
aware of okay anyway there must be
because when I use my melee it looks
like a stamina bar but the icon is of
someone running hey oh yeah you want to
get up close and personal big mistake
okay he bet he I why isn't he dying yet
oh I'm out of steam and I stopped mail
laying a long time ago uh
I'm an idiot I am an idiot plain and
simple that's just the way it is okay I
guess I gotta blow up the debris over
here maybe oh well how am I gonna get
there hold the walls or another door aha
there's another door it should have been
obvious but it wasn't us as we have
previously discerned I am an idiot I'm
about to run out of ammo too I mean what
do they expect me to do once I run out
of ammo just go melee only I haven't
seen any place to kind of recoup my ammo
of course me missing all the time
probably doesn't help it's weird the
whole environment is very smooth
shadowed but from some reason my
character model is not even the enemy
character models are smooth shadowed how
about you screw yourself okay what's in
here
bathroom ammo ammo bathroom no okay let
me melee this one drip what that didn't
one shot him Oh what's the deal
seriously what's the deal why is it no
longer one shotting him it did before a
crap ah crap I'm boned I'm boned I'm
boned on bone I'm bone you know how I
stole if I ain't stole your [ __ ] your
[ __ ] stool [ __ ] get dead
seriously stop moving there we go I have
five bullets left
good great that's fantastic what am I
gonna do
I have no materials with oh this is
blocked - that's phenomenal oh no it's
not okay there we go
so that's why I only use this first is
this a shot oh yes the shop okay whoa
$15.00 gets me max ammo I probably
should have tried that a long time ago
okay so I definitely need a damage
upgrade bigger clip only one you give me
one bullet bigger clip and that's it
100 more ammo man
there's a stringent stringent strict I
don't know I don't even know what that
is
it's like a mini gun I could buy can't
got that shotgun would be nice
wait a minute do I have a shotgun don't
tell me I actually do have a shotgun on
me I haven't tried to cycle my weapons
so uh okay no yes I do I do have a
shotgun that I completely overlooked Wow
how did I miss that I guess they didn't
tell me so I mean it's not totally my
fault right right right
it's gonna blow oh okay I'm gonna go in
this shotgun this time another feeling
well my shotguns not really upgrade so I
don't know if it'll be much better uh
nope seems like crap unupgraded oh good
golly get out of here okay the music got
way more drum hello gimme I'm on a run
here time for the shotgun man it is not
good to run in gun with this oh god
they're gonna kill me god damn it
they're everywhere they're swarming all
over me I think this is where I die is
probably where I die God my upgrades do
not do [ __ ]
ah he exploded oh did I do that or did
that damage me I'm still kind of alive
so man if I run I'm just running
backwards while trying to do this is
just giant piles of suck get out of here
you're like a mixture of the tow uh-huh
you're probably not even near the worst
enemy that I'm gonna face you ass bags
you ask bags are just every all over the
place just yeah get off of me get your
ugly ass off of me and go somewhere else
this is horrendous oh there we go there
we go okay Jesus finally good God let's
try to finish this one campaign maybe
I'm not I'm probably not gonna get
anywhere near finish to it I'm just
dipping my toes into the
death and destruction that is this game
I mean it's not bad I'm complaining a
lot but then I [ __ ] and moan about
everything I do the game is actually
really cool and I'm actually having a
lot of fun now despite my I got off of
me I'm actually enjoying myself quite a
lot this game is really cool I like I
said before I do enjoy these run-and-gun
sort of style games but I have no real
clear idea of why I'm in this place to
begin with so you know I'm just running
him in circles yeah boom this seems like
it would be easier to run and gun with
just BAM and then run reload right a
little more oh I um did how did I do
that oh I can rotate my camera and I
zoomed in so don't know how i zoomed in
huh okay this yeah I can avoid damage
more but man oh well if I miss both then
also it's pretty bad there we go
last one nope stop moving there we go
okay so now I've done well and I'm
pretty much all out of time so what I'm
gonna do here is I'm gonna stop this
current video here and you guys let me
know if you want me to get some people
together and do a four-player co-op
because I think that would be a crazy
amount of fun it's like you know it's
like left for dead it's really fun a
co-op game designed for cope I bet I'm
pretty sure the game is designed for
co-op they might not increase the number
of monsters but just having more guns
focused on the monster would be of great
help to me because right now it's kind
of a pain to keep track of anything and
just run away and constantly reload like
that so let me know in the comments
below thank you guys so much for
watching try this game out for yourself
it's on Steam there is no link it's on
Steam so check it out there it's called
primal fears so thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
more videos that I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye
ha